foreign
hi Amy welcome to the Ramsey show what's
up
hi
um so I have a question
um I'm the second to youngest of seven
siblings
and typically due to my financial
situation I've noticed that whenever
we're out with family events or
vacations
it's kind of expected that I pay for
things oh no and
and by all means most of the time I
don't mind but when it's expected I kind
of get less Joy
out of the giving because I don't feel
like it's really giving
um and this can be like you know we're
out in the city and I everyone leaves
the cab and now I'm just the last one in
the car and so of course I pay for it or
they leave the restaurant and like
thanks for lunch Amy like I didn't say I
was gonna pay for this one but I guess I
will I don't know it
so you make more you make more than your
siblings
yes sir but by far and they decided that
means you have to pay for their stuff
what a pain in the butt I hate that for
you I hate that for you I just don't
know how to say you know like like do I
put the preface it by saying like Hey
we're gonna split the I don't know and
granted this all started I mean I'm I'm
34 years old so it's not like you know
it's been the case forever
but this all started I think about three
years ago
um about two years after covet I guess I
don't know
um I paid for a trip to Disney World for
my whole family that's something that
I've been wanting to do since a kid and
I I was able to do it because I was
financially ready to but ever since then
it's been this
you know what I mean here's the magic
word and you're gonna hate this you
gotta make either you got to make peace
as you're the person which I don't
recommend or it's usually going to take
one or two times that you say hey
everybody's everybody's picking up their
own check on this one and I would not
pull a fast one at a restaurant if
you've paid for the last four or five
checks I wouldn't just wait till the
waiter comes by and says uh everybody's
on separate check I would tell people as
you're heading out and you're gonna get
one or two people who are like oh are
you serious yeah I'm serious and at some
point you just have to draw that line
and I would draw it with a smile on my
face
um and let that be and you'll find out
there's gonna be one or two of your
siblings that wants nothing to do with
you because you're not their Breadwinner
anymore or they think you're oh you're
too fancy or you don't care about that's
that's on them to do that but I I would
draw that boundary with a smile and as
gently but as directly as possible up
front
in advance clearly
and and it's it's like you have this 30
seconds of awkwardness and then it's
over
and so I do that we do that with friends
you know like
um and so you know we're going somewhere
and we go okay guys we're picking this
part up and we're splitting the rest of
it or you know like I had a whole bunch
of my buddies golfing buddies uh went to
one of my houses to look to stay and
play golf and I'm Furnishing the house
uh so they're buying dinner
[Laughter]
I mean that's fair that's fair I mean I
got a lot more in it than they got in it
right at the end of the day right so
they came out pretty dadgum good so yeah
I'm like okay guys y'all figure out when
we go out to the internet who's paying
because you're treating me and can I say
this and I just laugh about it and it's
over and they're cool they don't mind
not only are they cool they're mine
never mind at all nobody I don't say
nobody very few people love 100 free
ride and so if if even if Dave is is
paying for the hotel and he says Dylan
will you grab my bags yes I get to do
something right like there's I get some
skin in the game here or if Dave's
covering this and this and this hey
y'all covering dinner you think God yes
I'm all in like I want to be able to
jump I jumped on these guys and you know
what that but all it is you just said up
front you don't wait until you get over
at the restaurant and go hey guys I'm
gonna do an announcement here in the
restaurant you know that's just weird
and so no we'll just talk about it you
know when the car ride over go hey by
the way guys here's how we're doing this
this week or even before we go on the
trip I'm gonna cover the house is on me
you know you know and y'all don't have
any rent and so you're buying my food if
everybody's coming to the city I'll pick
up all the cabs we're gonna everybody's
gonna pick up their own check for dinner
y'all figure it out but I'm not in and
so I I am not here to take care I mean
Amy what do you do for a living
I'm an engineer and my husband's an
engineer as well so yes we're part of
the standard I was going to say you're
also uh super gifted at hard
conversations huh they don't they don't
have that class in the engineering
curriculum right
In fairness I shifted more to the
business side so now I have I am in that
role now okay yeah so I don't mind
having it it's just it's it's the fact
that I would I would love to pay for it
when it's not expected because I like to
do that I would love to pay for it when
I want to pay for it exactly otherwise
the love is gone hey can I tell you
another thing um one time I I had a
pretty significant accomplishment it was
an academic thing and one of my advisors
took me and my wife out her and her
husband took me and my wife out this is
one of my big like big faux pas I was
young and I was kind of brash and idiot
and I
she took us out as a celebration for an
accomplishment and I snuck around and
gave the waiter my debit card
and when the bill came it was already
paid I saw the look on my advisor's face
and it was one of sadness I had taken
her opportunity to give me a gift away
and I tell you that to tell you
sometimes people just get in this rut of
I'm just gonna do it this way I'm going
to do it this way I'm going to do it
this way let let people carry their own
weight some letting people carry their
own weight sometimes is a gift to them
yeah just all you got to say it start
about 30 seconds of awkward it's over
now we've got Clarity yeah it's easy and
we move on and five out of the seven of
them will be like that's cool and two of
them will be like oh you're six out of
seven and then the rest of them will
smack the one that's whining that's
right you know shut up she bought it she
took us to Disney shut up we're buying
dinner that's right shut up that's fair
you know that's cool and so that that is
fair and when the joy comes back once a
year you might want to pick up the whole
tab it's great it's okay but you say you
know hey I I want to take everybody to
dinner in advance and we booked the
dinner and it's preset that I'm doing
this as a gift
this is not the normal rhythm of things
right we're discussing the difference
ahead of time and the normal rhythm of
things is you pay your own way we go you
know we we split the bill you know and
so forth so uh you know that that you
don't know well it takes
when you run around with people whether
it's family or friends that start having
an expectation that you're paying for
everything
it uh damages the relationship every
time a hundred percent of the time so
that you're going to end up with damaged
relationships if you don't deal with
this tiny little thing and the other
side of that is if you have a family
member or a friend that picks up the tab
always offer and always make sure you
got money in your pocket to cover yours
yeah and don't ever get in that
entitlement syndrome like oh they're
paying they're paying their pain they're
paying always be ready to carry your
load man yeah exactly